il ne pousse rien à l'ombre des grands
arbres en cous il ne reste qu'un mois
allah te diront l'expression du maître
le hante encore un peu mais déjà
constantin beaucoup ci entame son
parcours original l'afrique au gain
contrebande passion à fleur de pierre le
fameux baiser 1910 le manifestement
désormais le roumain de paris construit
son univers et forme les 109
visage esquissé surface polie à l'infini
sont extrêmement lumière de méditation
rousies disait qu'il ne voulait pas que
c'était pas la forme qui l'intéressait
c'était l'essence sur la chose et comme
vous voyez vous avez vu dans cette
exposition quand il ya un portrait de
femme comme il ya des portraits ici le
mademoiselle pogany ou d'une danaïdes
c'est l'essence de la psychologie de la
femme qu'il a connue parce que ça part
toujours de modèles vrai dans la réalité
c'est l'essence qu'il a cherché et non
pas l'apparence minute ni douille un
mystère
m portant trop vite opéré hier en taille
directe
artisan perfectionnant ce qu'il fait
tout lui-même son inspiration fait
technique son audace ne laisse aucun
sculpteur à différents exemples les
oiseaux dans l'espace un mot miracle
dit-il
oh
par les deux sens de gravité devant un
oiseau qui est toute en hauteur peut
paraître bizarre mais c'était un aspect
du génie de brancusi qui sentait la
pierre et il ressentait la matière de
telle façon que même pendant des
tremblements de terre il y avait eu
comme celle ci qui ne sont pas tombées
mécène de cette première prendre dans ce
mythique
mozy legault pas va se faire partager et
faire aimer le langage plastique de
branques musique scooter inconnu de
sculptures célèbre aucun doute
maintenant l'auteur de ces créatures
peut dormir tranquille
il est enfin reconnu comme l'un des très
grands une 28 ans